hello everyone and welcome to day two of
the st. Louis rapid event after day one
here are the standings I forgot to show
them in my previous video so let's just
check that out for a moment after day 1
Aragon in first place would all three
wins in so lead with six points then
with four points Magnus Carlsen ending
Liron with three points we have Fabian
of Caruana Maxima Shilla Grove and
charger mamedyarov with two points you
young easterly hurricane Alicia the
report and in last place with one-point
linear Dominguez so these are the
standings after round one and on day two
for the first game we have Fabiano
Caruana formal Chess Championship
Challenger against Magnus Carlsen who is
the world champion and here well an
interesting bit of statistics you might
be interested in it
their all-time record in classical chess
okay it's 10 to 5 with 33 draws we know
that but we are interested in their
rapid score as this is a rapid game so
it's 17 to 8 with four draws so although
Carson is you know has a plastic or in
classical chess he has an even higher
plus score in rapid chess and also it's
very interesting as all of the 12 games
in their 2018 vulture championship match
were drawn across and defeated Caruana
basically in rapid chess so it's always
interesting one to two of them meet in
rapid events so now without further ado
well we were just one more thing some of
you have been asking me why how come
you've got unsubscribe from the channel
I think it's a basically new YouTube
algorithm sometimes I will mention it if
you don't comment on videos YouTube will
think you're a nun active subscriber and
then they will unsubscribe you but you
can just check for example every 1st of
the month if YouTube did this and if it
did you are welcome to subscribe back so
let's check out the game
Fabiana with the white pieces opens with
E 4 we have C 5 by Carlsen again
everyone was interested will we see
another line of this fashion curve
another super engine line so to say we
have Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and now
Bishop to b5 Khurana goes for the news
Medina were awfully mo variation with
ECX by Carlsen and now the shop captures
on c6 b captures and deep
with Knight to e7 the same as Carson
played against Gideon Zagreb in the
Grantchester we've covered that game it
was very nice but in that game Geary
went immediately for h4 but here Khurana
finds a sort of an improvement to the
position b3 first so waiting to see what
Carlson will play with Knight to g6 now
and only now that cost and put the
knight on g6 now Caruana goes for H for
preparing h5 to kick away the knife from
g6 with h5 by cross and not allowing it
and there is only one giving the
database for Bishop to b2 was played but
here Fabi plays a five and it is now
already as of move eight in the Sicilian
that we have a completely new game which
is just crazy
so crossing weights no longer he
challenges the center with f6 Fabi
continues Knight bTW you saying that I
don't mind if we capture the pawn
because if he captures the pawn then the
idea is a Knight to c4 just going after
that point with both nights and after
these six defending Queen e2 and this is
just a hard position to play for black
if you're not if you don't know the
lines by heart for example if you play
some Bishop e7 already Queenie four is
deadly attacking the knight and the c6
pawn so here across and doesn't bother
himself with the pawn of course he knows
Bobby's the most likely more prepared in
this line as he played a five the new
the new line with b6 again challenging
the center and now Fabi captures eke a
person B 6 and now not capturing Magnus
has plans of recapturing with the Queen
but first he 5 we have Bishop to b2
and now we have Bishop to g4 as the
point is already on h4 you don't have to
worry about
h3 so that Bishop is very nice there we
have Queen to e2 again with ideas of
going Queen to e4 with this well
not that but with this double attack so
cross and now captures with the Queen
if Queenie 4 comes already for example
if Queenie for the c6 pawn is already
protected Crossing can just play King f7
the knight is defended or always very
nice so after Queen captures and b6
fabric plays g3 takes away the f4 square
from Carlson's Knight Bishop d7 continue
continuous development and now Fabi
castles Queen side we have night the
wait now Magnus wants to get the night
over to e6 from where it can go over to
well not f4 but it can come to to d4
which is a very nice square we have
rogue DT one a nicer square for the rook
as the Magnus King is still in the
center and Knight the e6 with Quinta e4
now with ideas of going Queen to g6
check maybe not now but you know it is a
threat and here cross and played Queen
to d5 it seems like a very normal move
of course if Fabi captures then Magnus
gets the fixes pawn structure which of
course would be excellent for him but it
doesn't work here Magnus falls in fabi's
preparation and Fabi just executes a
deadly idea but feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this deadly
idea while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent executioner of deadly ideas
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show Knight captures on e5 and
here the problem is next if you decide
to capture a piece would F captures on
e5 then fabi's idea was f3 just trapping
the bishop there for example after let's
say Queen captures here you will get D
captures and now the bishop has no
escape square as this square is covered
by the pawn so you'll have to capture
and then after Knight captures yes the
material on the board is equal but Fabi
has three point islands and his pawn
structure is well much better whereas
Carlson has four point islands and this
point will come over the board very soon
and all the other pawns are very weak so
it would be a it would be very hard for
Magnus to play this on the other hand
after F captures on e5 if the knight is
captured and the Queen g6 seems like a
good idea but it's not for example after
Queen g6 checking d7 and now f3 it
doesn't work because you can create an
escape route for the bishop you can go
neither fate attack the Queen and make
an escape route for your bishop and now
if Queen captures and g7 rook h7 now
Queen captures on a5 Bishop captures on
f3 and here black comes up top we have
Knight captures on f3 Queen captures on
f3 and the rook nicely helps out with
the defense of the bishop here
everything is fine for black
so very nice preparation by Fabien
Magnus decides of course not the
character he plays Queen captures on e4
we have d captors on e4 and now F
captors on e5 and now Fabia continues
with his plan with f3
Magnus goes Knight the d4 there's no
saving the bishop but now he creates an
escape route for the bishop so far he
has to react to this with F capture
Sanji 4-h captures on g4 and now Knight
to c4 Fabi just goes after the weak
bones now and here it's already very
very hard for Magnus to defend for
example if Bishop f6 defending 93 will
pick up the g4 pawn so also not
something you want to do on the other
hand if you try a night here attacking
the rook anyone just rook eater f1 and
whatever black plays let's say castles
you can always go just 93 and you're
still gonna capture the g4 pawns start
pushing the pawns on the Kings side
so here magnet decides we're not gonna
defend anything here we just Castle and
now okay now it's not all that safe to
capture if you capture on e5 now Bishop
d6 attacks the night when you move it
now Magnus starts picking up the King
side points so here Fabi says okay
there's no rush after crossing castle we
have King Tubby one and now comes Luke
to F to Magnus to Grubbs activity which
is rook preparing to develop the other
rope maybe to f8 with Knight captures
and he 5 finally Fabi goes after the
pawn ready to capture on g4 and now
Knight captures on c2 Fabi captures on
g4 and now rook the g2 getting the rock
out of the way
rook eat the g15 he wants to get rid of
across since a very active rook rook
back to e 2 and here Fabi starts pushing
with
h5 and here it's a very strange moment
where Magnus decided not to capture on
e4 but it seems to be it seems to be a
free pawn because after Luke captures if
the King captures well you capture the
knight here for example King characters
here rook captures here and now whatever
you play h6 Bishop f6 and black defense
and he wrapped his pawn back for example
if you capture here King captures and
you are still worse but you know you are
still in the game here across and played
c4 he wants to play c3 and create some
complications on the Queen side
Fabi continues with
age six and now you have to decide what
to do here
Magnus could have gone four nights to a
three trip and it's a really really
tough line especially for a rapid game
because after Bishop captures and Bishop
captures you get h7 check King to h8 and
now Knight to e5 and this is when you
see this you don't want to play this
Knight g6 already threatened checkmate
you have to play g6 to unwind for
example g6 knife captures King g7 and
now h8 Queen you have to now give up
material route captures Knight captures
and c3 does look scary but wet can just
offer back a material and the white will
come on top for example Ruby to check
King to e want now rue goes back to e to
and now you go rook C to F 1 preparing
night to f7 to get your knight back into
the game and if c2 it's not a problem
knight of seven and once black wins
material you will play rook captures
Bishop captures rook captures King
captures and you get the same game where
white white is white is winning as he is
of material yeah you can capture on c6
but capture here you have three points
black has only one so this is a winning
endgame but you don't have to calculate
all this way as long as you see this 95
idea with 96 threatens mate you will
decide not to go for this so Magnus
plays c3 attacks the bishop and first
Bobby goes h7 check so the idea is
similar with King to f7 now King h8 runs
into the same 95 idea
so King to f7 and now Bobby doesn't go
for h8 Queen it would be well it
wouldn't be all that great as the bishop
here is under attack
so instead first looked f1 by Fabi with
Bishop to have sex blocking and now
still not Bishop characters on c3 for
some reason Fabi doesn't enjoy
complications here with a knife to a3
check maybe black could get some
perpetual ideas who knows so just brush
up the c1 that the show that point is
basically now blocking this dark square
Bishop so far we prefers this here we
have night the B for my madness and now
Magnus of course is hoping for a cheap
queen then you of course see how magnus
wins this you don't even have to pause
the video c2 is checkmate as the night
covers the pawn and the bishop slices
over all the way to a-1 so Bobby of
course will not play this he did not
become a World Championship Challenger
by pushing pawns for no reason
with a 5 just blocking the dark square
bishop and this is not beautiful you
cannot move the bishop as it spins so
whenever Fabi once he can just capture
it and here Carlsen can go for c2 check
but it's still not doing anything for
example King a 1 there's no continuation
to the attack if you try rook captures
on e5 trying to freed the dark square
Bishop
white will just capture but you still
can't capture the bishop is pinned King
e6 now white can capture here rook
captures on f6 and after the bishop is
eliminated in just h8 Queen and that's
it black black has no counter play so
after E 5 with rook captures on a 2
again now Magnus hoping for h8 Queen now
it's the same idea you no longer need
the Bishop c2 is again mate the knight
defends the pawn and the rook
so after this rook captures on a 2
Bobby has the defense C - so 93 only
move that defense C - favi plays it and
now we have looked to h8 magnus now has
to defend the queening square finally he
captures on f6 and now g5 trying to
block all the points the King now blocks
this point the rook blocks this one but
it's a very passive position if you have
to use your king and rook to block pawns
we've looked the d1 by Fabi offering the
c2 check but it doesn't bring Magnus
much for example if c2 check Knight
captures uncie - you will get rook
captures and c2 and now Bishop captures
and g5 and after you move the rook let's
say rook f2
just rook d7 check you will go King e6
roof east seven check King - f5 and now
room g7 and there is no defense against
rook g8 where you will either win rook
or win a queen or or get a queen into
the game so after Luke d1 with a five by
Magnus he has to create more
complications that is his only option we
have looked at before now you can
continue pushing because of rook
captures night but that's not the only
problem here at Magnus played see to
check with Knight captures and c2 and
cat purrs and c2 and now of course
Bobby's idea is pretty clear
he plays Knight rook captures night
which is the defender of the roof so if
Magnus captures he loses the rook here
Magnus sorry not today for obviously
Magnus played rook captures and c1 check
with King captures on c1 and now eight
characters than before so the material
and the material is a bit you know
almost the same five you have only one
pawn but Fabi plays the absolute best
move so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the absolute best
move in this position if you want to be
an excellent player of M games while I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player of end games and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
rook to h6 you do have to defend the f6
point if you want to win the game the
problem is if you try a rook f1 you no
longer defend the h7 point and by
playing group to h6 the beauty is that
now this pawn guards sorry not that this
pawn guards this square this pawn guards
this square and regards this square so
basically you have a wall created
against the black king so the black team
cannot approach the position at all so
black it's hopeless here you cannot move
the King you cannot move the rook if you
move the rook h8 just pushing the pawn
wins and black will just have to wait
for Fabi to bring his skin into the game
gobble up all the pawns push the beep on
the Fabi wins this game with playing
whatever so really an amazing game and I
think yeah maybe maybe the score I've
shown you the regarding the rapid chess
was was wrong yeah I think as I took it
today it already included today's games
so yeah up until up until this this is
the score including this game 17 to
eight before this game it was 16 to 8 so
yeah sorry about that I just realized
that as I finished recording this game
but yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Mark
sorrel and Jesse bernstrom and Leo stone
Hawaii for a contributor to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos so thank all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing well
everything we are continuing the
Capablanca saga checking up on your
suggestions and containing the short
coverage of the
who is a rapid em blitz event thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day
well I'm continuing enjoying my vacation
season